quand on dit que la désinformation n'a
pas de limite c'est vrai tant sur terre
que dans l'espace surtout depuis
quelques mois alors que pour toutes
sortes de raisons les extraterrestres
sont au goût du jour et les objets
volants non identifiés abattu récemment
au-dessus du territoire nord-américains
n'ont fait qualimenter une foule de
théorie que la Maison Blanche a aussi
tout tenté de déboulonner
quoi
bien travers toute cette confusion une
chose demeure certaine les scientifiques
et des entités gouvernementales redouble
d'efforts pour tenter de comprendre les
nombreuses apparitions inexpliquées
observées au fil des ans
Marie-Pierre il y a clairement un regain
d'intérêt de curiosité je sais pas pour
la question des ovnis est-ce que ce
regain là et aussi de nature
scientifique j'ai un peu cette
impression là mais peut-être que je me
trompe mais semi en tout cas il y a
clairement la démonstration d'une
volonté de montrer qu'on fait un effort
d'analyse rigoureuse du phénomène de la
part du Département de la Défense des
États-Unis il y a même un rebranding du
mot OVNI lui-même dorénavant on ne parle
plus du FO en anglais en identified
flying objectif mais de UAP en idende
phénoménat
en français ça donnerait des paniers
des phénomènes aériens non identifiés on
en a pas beaucoup entendu parler de ce
nouvel acronyme blanc français mais bon
on parle maintenant plus de phénomènes
que d'objets peut-être justement pour
nous éloigner du mythe de la soucoupe
volante
donc c'est indéniable il y a un genre de
frénésie que c'est vraiment concrétiser
quand les membres du Congrès ont demandé
au Pentagone de former un groupe
entièrement dédié à l'étude des
phénomènes aériens non identifiés et
même de produire des rapports annuels à
ce sujet là donc en avril 2020 il y a eu
la déclassification de plusieurs
documents dont une vidéo qui a beaucoup
circuler où on voyait des pilotes de
chasse qui suivaient un genre d'objets
ovale
identifier et tout dernièrement en
janvier il y a eu un rapport de publier
là on parle en tout de l'analyse de 366
observations et c'est pas un scoop il y
en a aucune qui a été formellement
cataloguée comme étant une soucoupe
volante ou un quelconque vaisseau venu
d'un autre monde Marie-Pierre si je
comprends bien on cherche pas
nécessairement à si c'est vrai si ça
existe ou non mais plutôt quels sont les
explications derrière les apparitions
que certains voient parce que ça il y a
aucun mal à l'affirmer avec toute la
rigueur scientifique du monde les ovnis
existent les objets existent mais oui
parce que la chronique objet volant non
identifié ou même le nouveau phénomène
aérien non identifié on parle pas
d'ovettes d'objets volants
extraterrestres on parle juste c'est
simplement on observe quelque chose on
n'a pas d'explication et donc on ne peut
pas l'identifier c'est tout donc le
consensus scientifique c'est que on n'a
pas besoin d'invoquer les
extraterrestres tant il y a des
explications qui sont plus plausibles
plus plausées plus logique exemple
de choses bon le fameux ballon chinois
les premières personnes qui l'ont vu
pour ces personnes là c'était
véritablement ça ça correspond à tout
point à la définition d'un OVNI une
espèce de grosse boule blanche qui
flotte dans le en plein jour
rapport qui a été publié par le
Pentagone
45% des observations pouvaient être
catalogués comme étant des ballons ou
des entités ressemblantes à des ballons
les petits points lumineux Marie-Pierre
qui se déplace d'un côté à l'autre puis
disparaît ça ensuite une explication
pour ça ressemble beaucoup à
la constellation de satellites sterling
qui sont lancés par
exactement et c'est exactement ça que ça
ressemble à une espèce de petit train
céleste qui finit par disparaître et
souvent les observations de ce genre-là
coincide avec le lancement de ces
satellites là
des petits points lumineux dans le ciel
ça peut aussi avoir une explication
purement météorologique donc de banal
éclairs ou des éclairs un peu moins
banal qu'on appelle des sprites en
anglais ça peut survenir quand le les
éclairs excitent le champ électrique
au-dessus des nuages et ça ressemble à
des genres de feu d'artifice au dessus
des nuages il existe aussi des genres de
Halo aux allures apocalyptiques on les
appelle des Halles punchcloud en anglais
existe des mots français soit cavum ou
trou de virga je sais pas si tu as déjà
entendu ça en tout cas c'est assez
spectaculaire et ça peut survenir quand
par exemple les gouttelettes qui forment
les nuages se retrouvent dans un état
très instable elles sont à l'état
liquide mais en dessous du point de
congélation il suffit qu'un avion passe
par là ou un gros coup de vent pour que
par exemple elle puisse s'évaporer
instantanément puis ça fait un gros trou
dans les nuages il existe des vidéos
très SPECT dont une qui avait été filmée
de l'intérieur d'une voiture en 2009 à
Moscou est vraiment on pourrait croire
là qu'un portail extraterrestre qui
s'est ouvert dans le ciel
mais pour maintenant le dire Alexis il y
a une catégorie d'OVNI qui sont
indéniablement d'origine extraterrestre
je parle de mes théories d'Alexis
souvent les météorites se retrouvent sur
des vidéos
comme quoi on observé quelque chose
qu'on n'arrive pas à expliquer la
plupart des météorites c'est un grain de
sable donc une petite trace lumineuse
dans le ciel une étoile filante rien de
très spectaculaire ou de surnaturel
là-dedans mais il y en a quelques-unes
qui sont beaucoup plus grosses on parle
d'une dizaine de centimètres et ça ça
peut faire vraiment des boules de feu ou
même des espèces de flash lumineux qui
apparaissent et qui disparaissent donc
on peut confondre ça avec un vaisseau
spatial ou que sais-je et il y a
plusieurs vidéos qui qui circulent et
qui nous montre simplement des
météorites et puis est-ce qu'il y a pas
de nous-mêmes dans tout ça on peut pas
nous-mêmes être à l'origine d'une
méprise d'un malentendu une chose qu'on
croit avoir mais n'existe pas tel qu'on
le conçoit mais absolument notre cerveau
nous fait parfois voir des choses qui
n'existent pas besoin
et on n'est pas en train de dire que
les gens imaginent avoir vu des choses
ou qui délirent en disant ça non c'est
même tout le contraire le cerveau c'est
un maître dans l'art de nous faire voir
des choses qui ne sont pas réelles c'est
tout le principe des illusions d'optique
qui peuvent souvent être très très
troublante
très attentivement comme toujours depuis
tantôt il y a toujours pas de preuves
qu'un petit i existe pas quelque part
[Musique]
évidemment qu'on peut pas prouver
l'inexistence de quelque chose donc non
je ne pourrais pas prouver qu'il y a pas
un petit outil derrière tous ces ovnis
qui sont observés un peu partout dans le
monde là ça devient intéressant de se
poser la question justement c'est
pourquoi devant quelque chose qu'on
n'est pas en mesure d'expliquer on a
souvent tendance à se réfugier dans dans
les autorériques dans l'extraterrestre
alors que dire il y a plein
d'explications plus logique où on peut
simplement aussi humblement se dire
qu'on ne sait pas ça fait peut-être
partie de la nature humaine mais ça en
soit à mes yeux s'en est un phénomène
inexpliqué